- Du bist in letzter Zeit nicht
so gut vorbereitet, Selma.
- Tut mir leid.
- Du bist immer noch gut.
Ich meine nur
ist alles in Ordnung?
- Ja, ja.
Ich habe nur viel Stress.
- Dein Praktikum ist wohl ziemlich
anstrengend, ha?
- Ja, aber es macht auch großen Spaß!
Architektur ist super interessant und
mein Chef ist sehr zufrieden mit mir.
- Ja, alles andere würde
mich auch wundern.
- Wir nehmen gerade an einer
Projektausschreibung teil.
Das ist total spannend.
- Aha. Worum geht es denn?
- Es geht um den Entwurf für
eine neue Brücke
und ich darf auch einen Vorschlag machen.
Und der Gewinnerentwurf wird
vielleicht wirklich gebaut.
Stell dir das mal vor:
Eine richtige Brücke!
- Wow. Selma, das ist …
das klingt großartig.
- Danke. Aber es ist eigentlich ein
Wettbewerb für junge Architekten.
Die können und wissen natürlich
viel mehr als ich.
Es ist also sehr unwahrscheinlich,
dass ich gewinne.
- Aber es ist ein Anfang!
- Bis dann!
Ich bin schon sehr gespannt
auf deine Brücke!